for those of you who just want to get on
with the tips they're time stamped below
but more than just saving money i really
wanted to first explain why i thought it
was important to make this video so that
you can know your motivation as you go
through this list recently i've gotten
into the habit of writing down every
single one of our expenses to try to
figure out where we're spending the most
in and what we can cut back on oddly
enough i was surprised when i shared
with my husband that the category we
spent the least amount of money in is
our kids i was reading through the
comments on avery's channel talking
about how he saves 80 of his income and
i noticed a lot of comments stating
things like it's not achievable for
people with families and it's not
possible if you have kids so i tried to
be a little bit of an encouragement and
state that it certainly is possible by
giving a few quick tips and i got this
response
until they become teenagers and know
they're poor i'm not quite sure how to
take it i'm guessing it means that you
can give your kids a simple lifestyle
while they're young but then they'll
grow up and then they'll realize that
they're poor to which i lovingly respond
that both my husband and i grew up poor
my husband was worse off than i i
remember at one point in my life having
to share one meal with our family
and my mom's saying
i'm not hungry now i realize she was
hungry but she wouldn't eat to give me
her portion
my husband actually had days where he
had absolutely no food and he got a belt
whooping if he dared ask for food
because there was none he left the home
at 16 to be able to provide for the
family and slept on trees on more than
one occasion
fast forward many years we now live in
the usa and we are so blessed to never
have to worry about having food on the
table and yes our kids toys are very
minimal our wardrobes are as well you'll
see me repeating the same outfit on
several occasions but by no means would
i classify that as poor the question
that we asked ourselves is this do we
want our kids to base their happiness on
material possessions
or the relationships and memories that
they create
we choose the later of the two and this
is the entire reason why we choose and
love a minimalist lifestyle is because
it allows us to live the life that we
want a life where our focus is not on
acquiring more and a feeling of
emptiness as we realize there's always
something that we need or that we lack
but rather a feeling of freedom as we
let go of the excess and we find
ourselves perfectly content with
simplicity
some of the things on this list may seem
a little too extreme for some people and
that's okay we know our why so as we
continue on with this list keep in mind
that the things that you choose to do or
not do will depend on your why for doing
it you may choose to do only a few on
these list and that's perfectly okay as
long as it provides value for your
family so i'm really not trying to tell
you to do all of these things i'm just
trying to encourage and motivate you by
showing you some ideas that maybe you
hadn't thought of also i recognize that
some of you may have older kids so the
baby stuff will be towards the end of
the video okay all of that being said if
you like this video please give it a
thumbs up because it really helps out my
channel but if not then by all means
thumbs it down but please give me some
feedback in the comments so i know what
to work on number one buy all black
socks when our first was walking and
constantly pulling socks off or losing
them or leaving the white ones looking a
bit yucky we decided to simplify our
life by buying a pack of all black socks
this saves us from having to look for
lost loners when she outgrows them we
can pass them on to her son she does
have a couple of white ruffled socks for
dresses but otherwise this just makes
things easier and no more buying socks
number two always pack snacks and drinks
when going somewhere even if you think
it's just going to be a short trip just
in case it takes a little longer than
planned for example when my husband and
i take detours and get lost at the toy
store home depot and then we end up
buying whatever is at the checkout line
because we didn't bring a snack or a
drink
number three don't buy special event
clothes or holiday clothes unless you're
planning like a special family photo or
something kids really don't need a new
outfit for every holiday
number four sell your kids gently use
clothes if you did buy the special
holiday outfit or your daughter some
expensive carhartt overalls that she
only wore once
you know who you are
then you can sell your kids gently use
clothes to either other people online or
consignment or thrift shops number five
buy used clothing this goes without
saying kids outgrow their clothing so
quickly so you can save tons of money
with this tip alone but if you don't
like the idea of your kids using used
clothes then there are actually also
consignment shelves that sell clearance
style items for stores at a discounted
price when we want to buy our kids new
shoes for example we shop at a
consignment store that sells clearanced
out target items
for less than half the price so check
out stores that might be in your area
number six don't buy toys that your kids
will outgrow quickly or that won't last
buy toys for a wide age group for
example wooden blocks musical
instruments or animal figures
as an example we don't have a rattle for
our baby if he wants to he can have at
it with some maracas
or he can throw wooden blocks everywhere
keeping in mind that you keep the toys
safe of course like no small parts the
toys that your older kids use can work
just as well for your smaller kids for
more on the topic of toys i highly
recommend the parenting junkies video on
the 10 categories of toys that kids need
number seven once your kids have the
amount of toys that you want for them to
have don't buy them new toys instead
allow them to play with random objects
for example that cardboard box that you
were about to throw out or that empty
formula can that makes a great drum
i love to give my daughter random
objects because i use her i'd see her
use her creativity and also because it's
a new toy it sparks her curiosity and
then once she's done and she's bored
with it i can just toss it out like i
intended anyway sometimes the random
objects in the house are actually the
ones that they enjoy the most give me a
thumbs up emoji if you ever played with
random objects around the house and let
me know what it was
number eight buy one toy collection that
is meant for all your kids to share and
only have a few toys that are specific
for each child for example we purchased
several categories of toys like musical
instruments cooking set blocks and the
expectation is that these toys are to be
shared they do have a few toys that are
specific to them that are special for
them and these toys tend to be christmas
or birthday gifts from family
number nine buy used furniture like beds
lamps side tables or make your own
furniture if you can
this trundle bag was a hundred dollars
and really all it needed was some paint
my husband built a rail and voila we can
use the trundle for another bed or use
it as storage
number 10 avoid purchasing special
character items or prints and patterns
that they may quickly outgrow this can
mean princess blankets superhero book
bags unicorn cups lamps you name it once
they've outgrown this or they're moved
on to the next special character that
they like you're out having to purchase
all this stuff all over again instead
buy something that's simple but yet
tasteful that they can use for years to
come also this can teach them that they
don't always need to have the latest
trend and can help them instill in them
from the very beginning that consumerism
is not what will lead them to happiness
number 11 child care for a lot of
parents this is easily the category they
spent the most amount of money in if you
can try finding somebody that you know
or a family member if willing and able
to take care of your kids
and for some parents and some families
it actually works out better if one
parent stays home versus if both were
working just because of where they fall
in the tax bracket and the kinds of
financial assistance available to them
that wouldn't be if both parents were
working so explore your options and be
creative with this and also if you have
any recommendations on how to save on
this please share them in the comments
because this is easily one of the
categories that parents spend the most
on number 12 feed them what you eat if
you can try to avoid buying the
prepackaged foods and snacks for your
kids and have them eat the same things
that you do if you have a baby i highly
recommend checking out baby lead weaning
and seeing if it's right for you and
your baby number 13 don't get them used
to buying snacks or novelty items every
time you go to a store when i was a kid
i did not dare ask for something at the
checkout line because i knew what the
answer would be now if you want to do
that every now and then go ahead but
don't make it to where they expect it
every time
this will quickly drain your wallet
number 14 size up their winter jackets
let's face it puffy jackets are meant to
be big anyway so if you size them up
they will not only be able to layer them
for that winter but they can also use
them for the next season and this can
actually be done with boots and tennis
shoes in the winter by wearing them with
an extra sock i actually used to love
this when i was a child because my feet
were always warm number 15 use your
library you don't have to own every book
or movie and also check out if your
library has an app or an e-version to
where you can download books online we
use the hoopla app and we use it to
check out books but i have also seen
kids shows and movies as well and some
libraries also hold events where they
have
like little parties and things for kids
as well so check it out
number 16 for birthday and christmas
gifts ask that friends and family don't
give new toys and instead ask for what
they need for example craft supplies
that they may go through quickly
for christmas last year my adoptive mom
asked what our daughter needed and we
said that we wanted to build a farm
table
and she kindly gave us the money to buy
the material to make it this of course
is more special because daddy made it
but also she knows that it was possible
because of grandma
number 17 another option if your kids
are older ask them and see if they would
be willing to ask friends and family
that instead of giving gifts
to give to a charity for example like
saint jude's this will not really save
money however it can help shift their
mindset by focusing on giving and what
they can do for their community instead
of me me me i don't remember ever
receiving birthday or christmas gifts
from my parents when i was young but i
honestly wouldn't change this about my
past because i learned not to expect it
and my hope is that with our kids that
we can teach them to think instead about
what can i give what can i do what do i
have to offer at least that's the hope
anyway we'll see number 18 moving on to
baby stuff skip the bassinets the cribs
the toddler beds and go straight to a
floor bed
of course this goes without saying
always ensure safety first when we did
this with our daughter we had to make
sure that for example furniture wouldn't
fall on her there weren't toys that she
was going to be able to grab that were
going to
be a choking hazard so always ensure
safety but we loved this for many
reasons
of course it easily saved us cash by not
buying all those other items but when
she wasn't able to walk yet she could
crawl in and out of the bed on her own
it kind of gave her a little bit more of
independence also if it was a
particularly rough night i could just
crawl in the bed right with her and she
never had to get used to her big girl
bed because she was always in it
bassinets and cribs are only used for a
short time anyway and then you still
have to go and buy a bed so you can skip
that all together and just get it from
the very beginning also there's no worry
that she's gonna fall on the floor
because it's already on the floor number
19 don't buy baby shoes it was hard to
convince my husband that buying our kids
baby shoes was a waste of time and money
i mean they don't walk so they don't
need them and half the time you're
running around looking for the darn
things because they can't seem to stay
on their feet plus i think if i were a
baby i would want my feet to be comfy
not cute
number 20 for newborns and infants buy
as much gender-neutral as you can for
example clothes swaddles carriers baby
bottles all that sort of stuff if this
is your first child especially and you
plan to have more children kids outgrow
their clothes so quickly when they're
babies and so you have to buy a new
wardrobe every few months this easily
saved us a lot of money with our son but
it's also the case for big ticket items
like strollers and car seats get stuff
that can be passed down this can easily
save you hundreds
number 21 it may not be for everyone but
buy reusable diapers wipes and training
underpants when our daughter was born we
invested about five hundred dollars in
diapers and it has easily saved us
thousands now that she's potty trained
and her brother is not using them we
chose to buy ours new so it was a little
bit more pricey but you can buy them
online there's lots of parents trying to
sell their used diapers all the time so
if you're okay with that and you want
extra savings maybe check that out as an
option number 22 don't buy baby mittens
they fall off half the time anyway if
your baby is especially a houdini and
seems to scratch use socks instead i'm
telling you they look funny but they
work odd daughter especially had a tough
time with maxima and she would scratch
and bleed and socks were the only thing
that worked it may look funny but it
worked number 23 skip the transitional
eating utensils this tip is montessori
inspired but with our first we did not
buy the baby spoons the cups with the
handles on them or the sippy lids
instead what we did was we bought these
munchkin stainless steel cups that have
a sippy lid and a straw lid attachment
and i think she actually likes this a
lot better because our cups are
stainless steel so it makes her feel
like a grown-up and they can be used for
years to come
number 24 if your insurance offers it
get a free breast pump and breastfeed if
you can breastfeeding easily saves you
cash it's best for baby and can help you
get your figure back a big money saver
for me has also been having reusable
breast milk bags so that i don't have to
be constantly buying the disposable bags
number 25 don't buy trendy baby gadgets
babies don't really need those pacifiers
with the stuffed animals on them gliders
and walkers with our first we had a
walker that had music and buttons on it
and she actually preferred to sit down
and play with the buttons instead of
actually walking with it
of course buttons are more entertaining
so that was 25 ways to save with kids
but for sticking to the end my bonus tip
for you is adopt minimalism in your life
if as a whole you start to remove excess
from your life and become happier with
less it will in turn rub off on them as
they see that there is joy to be had in
simplicity if you have any ideas on how
to save money with kids please share
them in the comments it may be difficult
and may require creativity but it is
definitely possible so let's encourage
each other
hasta luego